yutz et squeeze aujourd'hui sauf pour la
suite de allen isolation comme premier
on se retrouve donc sur cette fameuse
échelle
qu'est ce qu'il y à là haut je ne sais
pas et vous ne savez pas et il ya une
salle voilà êtes vous déçu moi je ne
dirai rien on prend le fusillade et on
se casse d'ecija petite musique là qui
remonte un peu le moral
non non non attends la meuf peut être
dépressif comme l'autre finalement le
seul truc je vois une solution et de la
couper mais non mais non mais la
déception allez on s'enfuit au attendez
attendez attendez attendez moi comme
promenade fumigènes ou là qu'est ce que
c'est que ça sent tellement pas bon
c'est une maquette du vaisseau ben je
crois bien alors essayez de ce bal
nickel rétablir le courant je suppose
que d'autres côté c'est pareil fume pas
pourquoi j'essaie au planning toko bien
petits voyants rouges savent eux
rarement dire que tout va bien et que
c'est parti mon kiki
la seo attendait mais arrêtez ça arrêtez
c'est pas ça pour établir le courant
bonjour je veux dire à une xbox mag
grise au c'est ce qu'il faut dans
l'espace quand ils se font chier et
jouer à la xbox soit au [ __ ]
alors on va monter ses escaliers
qu'est-ce qu'il ya ici des écrans
utilisés ces terminaux pour mettre à
jour la carte
ah ah ah ah ok donc c'est comme ça ça
sécurise la carte très bien a
effectivement manqué à bas et yara
j'approuve léger mais rien qui marche
c'est d'un ringard après celle
informatique hacker ce que ray de corée
resterez pardon le courant du store donc
ces trucs là ça c'est à rétablir le
courant juste dans une pièce en fait je
crois
allez hop là c'est parti ça redémarre et
maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on fait ok on
dirait le dit d'une boîte de nuit à
hauteur comme ça dans ces fêtes la fête
les amis
c'est génial on se calme ah oui il faut
que j'ai accès au terminal gtv6 là alors
l'insee si tu cherches notre stock gelé
bouger tu l'avais laissée en plein
milieu n'importe où n'importe qui aurait
pu le prendre bordel tu sais ce que tu
me farcir pour la voir je les planqués
aux indes des cagibis tu devrais pouvoir
le retrouver le code c 03 40 hockey donc
03 40 surtout faut retenir ça je pense
que ça va nous servir ça c'est l'adieu
de sixun hockey un truc intéressant vous
pouvez être sûr que l'intelligence
artificielle centrale de 6 tonnes apollo
assez que ces androïdes lambda
continueront de service et sébastopol
jusqu'à ce que la dernière pièce soit
démonté au kenya d'android 1 à bord qui
a donc d'après ski 10 devrait être
encore là même si le vaisseau est un
véritable bordel utilitaire
embranchements rétabli au courant des
départs wee aa
voilà fait du bruit pour la soummam est
tout ce qu il ya des gens ya des gens il
ya des gens il ya des gens revenaient
revenait revenaient au score assez
rassurant c'est que l'on n'est pas seul
à bord au moins bon il n'avait pas l'air
d'une grande aide les mecs se passe au
courant il courait avec leurs jambes à
leur cou plus qu'autre chose mais bon et
ben bizarre moi j'ai plus envie d'aller
au quai une bof j'ai plus envie d'aller
là où il allait s'il te plaît non mais
c'est pas que ok d'accord on doit aller
là d'où ils venaient super ni qui fuyait
un truc et nous on va dans ce truc
orama ces objets mélange des mélanges
des packs de recharge à mon avis on va
pouvoir se kraft et des petits objets
qui vont nous aider
bah c'est pas par là non plus assez de
rita ou démarche alors ça devrait être
quelque part bordel mais regardez ça
fait vrai pour tous est devenue que bon
après quand tu vois les murs le décor et
le le taux de visite et du truc tu
comprends au bonjour ou là mon avis si
je ma copie pas ça me refaire les
cheveux l'a1 mais parie que ça augmente
la la la pilosité capillaire 1
mais bon après c'est pas prouvé
scientifiquement donc je vais pas
essayer et c'est aussi prouvé que quand
levé sur facebook la tumeur dans la
minute qui suivait bon après ça par
contre c'est prouvé scientifiquement
mais je me le demande mon ami je me le
demande
qu'est ce qui s'est passé mon
à toujours aller en hauteur pour avoir
un meilleur point de vue sur ce qu'il se
passe en bas je ne veux pas décider s'il
vous plaît ouvre son magasin
le directeur d'un magasin au nom mais il
papa ibra une collision entre les deux
vaisseaux à moi je mets au foetus
c'est le torrent mais non mais à tekken
ou cherche
bah oui le cherche on est là on est là
regard s'allume ça pour toi
y avez vous une dll il est là où tu
viens mais avec succès pourquoi les
stars se faire mon gars non [ __ ] de
stores mais non comme c'est comme le
soir avant de se coucher on ferme les
stores mais là il fallait pas en ont ils
sont complètement fermés
du coup on profite de la lumière du
soleil et des étoiles ne sais pas trop
quoi en mer n'est pas qu'est ce qu'on va
faire nous sommes dans la mouise up with
the wiz jusqu'où coup bonjour porte puis
je veux venir rétablir le courant comme
d'habitude
or il avait des jeux comme ça à bord
seront bien c'est génial ça c'est mieux
que la xbox ou en crise à moi je vous le
dit alors que c'est que saab six
générateurs utilise deux à temps mais
cette somme elle fait ça trois fois par
minute quoi je vous dis à la fin du jeu
elle a le poignet mais il a quadruplé de
volume elle fera du bodybuilding mai du
poignet uniquement à lebron de nous le
courant de cette pièce s'il te plaît
oula oula oula ok une petite pièce avec
de la lumière de la fumée pardon mais
aussi la lumière vous me direz oui il ya
une ombre dieu le permet je veux pas là
dedans je m'en bats les steaks alors là
là moi si tu veux qu'on sent qu'on se
rencontre autour d'une table de jeu
comme ça e à l'eau y at il quelqu'un ici
c'est oit le code qui a bougé cette
lumière bleue forcément le mec forcément
passer en plus c'est que s'est cogné la
tête d'un an la norme quoi qu'est ce
qu'on fait ici un os ça ça me plaît ça
me plaît une sauvegarde comme ça de la
partie à un petit terminal
alors qu'est ce qu'ils disent n'est pas
sans savoir que la boutique bat de l
aile depuis quelques temps déjà je ne
pouvait plus retenir les créanciers plus
longtemps il ya tout simplement plus
personne qui vient à sébastopol
on dirait que la station toute entière
est dans le rouge et qu'ils arrêtent
tout ils vont tout vendre pour des
miettes je suppose
ouais donc j'ai vraiment eu un gros
problème dans ce délire qu est ce qu un
polo apollo et l'intelligence
artificielle centrale qui surveille
assiste ou landes à 2,6 tonnes sur
sébastopol elle supervise également
toutes les communications sur la station
où que vous soyez vous est entre de
bonnes mains
sixun ensemble pour demain six jeunes
comme pour iphone abonnez-vous à lâcher
le 6 octobre par les chaînes alors
qu'est ce qu'on fait maintenant 1 parce
que là c'est bien beau les sous sous le
feu d'un projecteur pas des projecteurs
là je pense carrière regarder quand je
parle ça résonne carrément va retomber
là y'a pas moyen c'est hors de question
on va à bavois là où il ya une petite
trappe enfin conduit au lac et al est ce
la discothèque à et s'était conduit je
viens au p et partout les chemins je
reste en paix
et tellement déçu mais pas dire dans les
conduits on sait pas bon je n'aime pas
ça je n'aime pas ça qu'est ce qui s'est
passé à ya des vibrations au dessus je
pense qu'ils font vibrer les conduit
littéralement avec double conduite moi
sorti en escaladant olala ça c'est une
bonne grosse position de faiblesse
tu sais que tu es ohlala on est
tellement pas bien bon je suis je vais
pas chercher ses deux ports je suis
quasi sûr qu'il faut aller par là ça
paraît évident alors attention ticket de
métro ou retire à marsa oui tout pas en
morceaux comme tu dis ah ouais non mais
attends à l'écart dans toutes les
bouches images j'ai vu clair dans votre
petit jeu allez vas tu en voilà
c'est quoi ramassez camelot ok donc j'ai
de la camelote ça va nous permettre de
kraft et des objets je suppose oh là là
non mais les vibrations et où l ambiance
sonore du jeu elle est incroyable a
vraiment je viens en paix et par tous
les chemins
j'y reviendrai
et j'ai même pas envie de le croiser ce
mec il pas surtout à courir comme ça
tâter un marathon interview pour une
association j'en sais rien mais moi
c'est ça fait peur [ __ ] prévenez
prévenait je sais pas mettez les
affiches d'enlever sauvette des c'est
quelque chose quand aulas la non mais
attendez ça c'est des kanaks en fait
mais non mais regardez ces décors
c'était des gens décédés
[ __ ] et nous on est allé au milieu je
cherche mon hobby et nos supposés quoi
il parle
c'est la seule porte qui éclaire et
voilà bien évidemment oh là là ça sent
pas bon qu'est ce qu'il ya là dedans
c'est une sorte de queue de cantine
c'est ça j'ai pas on dirait la le
dortoir d'un mec une porte
non ça marche pas bien évidemment qu'est
ce qui marche la tendance vaisseau 1
qu'est ce qui marche bardel faut le dire
ici on a quoi ce odeurs ionique requis
très bien bien sûr là on peut pas y
aller on s'en trouvèrent j'aime pas ça
je vois bien une petite main comme ça
d'un enfant qu'ils m'attrapent le nez
qui fit la une porte avait annoncé sous
des radios ni critiquer ce qu'on a là
dedans oh merde y'a un mec est décédé
olala il est décédé puis les décédés
mais il a quand même le confort quoi il
ya un petit oreiller sous la tête comme
ça il ya un truc à ramasser juste là à
ça sent le roussi c'est moi qui vous le
dis ok ce qu'on fait alors attendez j'ai
quand même oublié de dire au revoir
notre seul ami même si les morses comme
notre seul ami dans adieu très dur pour
nous pierre et je propose qu'on art de
faire semblant
tu es mort pierre ah ben voilà ce qu'il
faut faire c'est parti on se muscle
poignet comme d'habitude
alors qui s'est ouvert au monde s'est
ouvert ici donc je suppose que ça c'est
pour faciliter l'accès aux trucs là haut
en faciliter l'accès notamment à la
chambre de l'homme mort oui oui j'en
suis sûr il faut que je reste le saut je
suis bien trop malade mais je suis
complètement taré et là je marche sur
les morts mais je suis encore plus tard
il puisque je pensais pas finir à passer
par la salle principale
je pense que c'est ça la salle
principale n'y at il pas un petit
endroit pour sauvegarder ans est sa
principale
ça m'arrangerait fortement ou alors une
arme un truc j'en sais rien bah voilà
drouot à droite à droite ça me plaît
beaucoup
voilà là je peux rentrer ici bordel oui
je peux entrer pourquoi ya du sang il ya
un mec cacher derrière la table même pas
ici folotyn maintenant c'est là tout
droit en facile ce qu'on y trouve un os
ou j'aime pas les réserves
y'a un mec là mais c'est notre deuxième
avis ces matières merde
bah oui baird effectivement merde il ya
quoi il a une clé dans la main robin
voilà un truc me permet d'ouvrir des
portes
mathieu mais comment je veux cette porte
mon gars à le conduit mathieu matthew
n'est matthew neige arrive à yao jian a
du sens ici donc un truc sur lui par ce
conduit au plat s'alluma thioune
ramasser l'outil de maintenance bah
voilà qui va nous permet d'ouvrir des
belles-portes slash tard sony plus bas
oui ah oui tu l'as bien d'y retirer la
tâche
bah voila mais ça c'est magnifique c'est
génial mais pourquoi on est face à des
le début sans déconner pourquoi il ya
des boules à temps mais pourquoi ils
mettent la pression alors qu'il se
passerait à quoi l'âge peut l'ouvrir aux
plages retient la tâche moi qu'est ce
qui se passe au laac étals de l'éthanol
c'est bien ça et un fichier auquel il va
nous dire plein de belles choses mais
voilà c'était juste à berlin il y en a
eu tout ce que vous voulez dans cette
vidéo finalement je suis désolé les gens
mais comme je vous ai dit je suis encore
soumis à la limite de 10 minutes par
vidéo vous touchez n'est pas encore
sortie merci d'avoir regardé deuxième
épisode j'espère que l'esprit et vous
plaît on se retrouve très vite dans une
nouvelle vidéo sur autre chose qu'elle
est mise en relation va varier le let's
play sur l'égalisation et sur les autres
jouent notamment what the fuck etc
bonne soirée mi-journée matinée jo tout
le monde puisse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]